hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the endosymbiotic theory this
theory is the explanation for how
scientists think the eukaryotic cells
first arose it also describes how
scientists think that eukaryotic cells
acquire two organelles specifically
mitochondria and chloroplasts so first
let's go through the steps it starts
with an early ancestral cell that has
developed a rudimentary endoplasmic
reticulum and a rudimentary nuclear
envelope by in folding of the plasma
membrane so here that membrane system is
shown in blue and the DNA is shown in
orange then one of these early cells
engulfed in aerobic bacteria aerobic
simply means that it's capable of
carrying out arabic respiration which
involves using oxygen to make ATP which
is the major energy currency of the cell
if you're interested in learning more
about aerobic respiration please see my
video on that topic so here we have this
early cell that engulfs this aerobic
bacteria it most likely does so through
some kind of phagocytosis event
Daigo cytosis is a type of endocytosis
which is how cells will bring in objects
from the external environment I also
have a video on endocytosis phagocytosis
and pinocytosis so take a look at that
if you're interested in that subject now
after this aerobic bacteria was engulfed
many many generations went by and over
time this bacterium its descendants
lost the ability to live independently
and they became full internal semi aunts
of the larger host cell this led to the
organelle that we know of as a
mitochondrion
so after this had happened and again
remember that there are many many
generations perhaps even millions of
years that that go by as the
mitochondria are developing from this
aerobic bacteria lineage then one of
these cells engulfs another bacterial
cell this one a photosynthetic
cyanobacteria and over many many
generations again this leads to the
organelle that we know of as the
chloroplast so we see here that there
were two endosymbiotic events the first
one where the aerobic bacterium was
engulfed into the mitochondrion and the
second one where the cyanobacteria
was engulfed leading to the chloroplast
so the fact that there were two windows
and biotic events one following the
other means that this entire thing is
known as a serial endosymbiosis now you
might ask how the scientists know the
order that this happened in how do we
know that the aerobic bacterium leading
to the mitochondrion was engulfed first
and that it was only much later that the
cyanobacterium leading to the
chloroplast was involved well scientists
know this from something called
phylogeny that is the evolutionary
history here we have a simplified
phylogenetic tree that shows all of life
we have the three domains bacteria
archaea and Eukarya which i've shown in
some more detail over here both the
aerobic bacterium and a cyanobacterium
came from somewhere along this bacterial
lineage but we're engulfed by a
Chester's leading to today's eukaryotic
self
we know that the aerobic bacterium was
involved first because more eukaryotic
cells had it that is almost all protozoa
as well as animals fungi plants and
algae have mitochondria there are only a
very few eukaryotic cells that don't
have mitochondria some of them may have
split off very early on before the
ancestor got engulfed the aerobic
bacterium did that others may have
simply lost their mitochondria after
having it for many generations simply
because their internal parasites and
they don't really need the mitochondrion
however most eukaryotic cells do have a
mitochondrion suggesting that the
aerobic bacterium was engulfed very
early in a eukaryotic lineage so that is
a bacterium from over here was engulfed
by itself over here the cyanobacteria
however its engulfment led to the
chloroplast of course chloroplasts are
only in a few different types of
eukaryotic cells mainly algae and plant
cells suggesting that be cyanobacterium
was engulfed by an ancestor of plants
and algae after it split off from the
lineages that led to persona animals and
fungi so again that cyanobacterium was
engulfed from over here by a more recent
ancestor of plants and algae so that is
how we know the order that the these
events happened in now let's look at
some of the evidence for the
endosymbiotic theory why scientists
think that these two organelles came
from bacterial cells it's because of how
many similarities there are between the
organelles and bacterial cells for
example the DNA eukaryotic cells have
year segments of DNA bacterial cells as
well as mitochondria and chloroplasts
have circular DNA this is something that
students often forget when they think
about DNA inside the cell they always
think about this DNA the nuclear DNA but
remember that mitochondria and
chloroplasts have their own DNA and it's
structurally similar to bacterial DNA
another one is ribosomes there are
ribosomes inside the cell eukaryotic
cell ribosomes are AES ribosomes that
has to do with their type of structure
whereas the ribosomes that are in
mitochondria and chloroplasts are 70s
ribosomes 70s ribosomes are the kind
that are also found in bacterial cells
further suggesting that these organelles
came from bacteria their type of
replication is also similar to bacterial
cells students will often forget that
chloroplasts and mitochondria can
actually replicate somewhat autonomously
in the cytoplasm of the cell and they do
so through a procedure very similar to
binary fission binary fission is how
bacterial cells replicate if you're
interested in learning more about binary
fission please see my video on that
topic there's also their size most
eukaryotic cells are about a hundred
micrometers bacterial cells as well as
mitochondria and chloroplasts are closer
to 10 micrometers so the sizes are
similar as well and finally the location
of the electron transport chain the
electron transport chain is used in
aerobic respiration and it is found in
the internal membranes of the
mitochondria and chloroplasts suggesting
again that these organelles are
descendants of bacteria capable of
aerobic respiration so that is it for
the endosymbiotic theory I hope you
learned a lot and thanks for
watching biology professor